hello everybody welcome to another
episode of genius brain I am your host
Joe chit Sakawa and I'm your host David
so and we have a very special someone
today by the name of Bart Kwan hello I
don't even know who this person is no
just kidding
I'm brand new to this show yeah it's my
first time you know originally when we
wanted to do a podcast it was like a few
years ago and we were thinking about
it's big us 3 yeah yeah yeah and there's
just too hard schedule oh yeah yeah I
think it became really difficult we all
kind of went off and made our own little
podcast it was because we also had go
for broke at the time true I mean we
were trying to do go for broke and then
try to do the pot it was JK news podcast
yeah yeah and then we also had way more
articles that we were doing at JK news
obtained same time so Aussie bow it was
damn near impossible yeah but hey
Cheerilee I care just for what they did
for one reason explain to me what the
[ __ ] the peace makers are did if you
guys don't know what the peace makers
are the peacekeepers are you need to
sleep peacemakers yeah it's peacemakers
okay you need to go back to the episode
of me and David I think it's called like
revenge of the Joe or some [ __ ] like
that
but I'm I'm telling David this story of
when I first kind of became friends with
Bart and then we would we would do him
and Mei together and all that stuff and
he told me he was a part of this group
called the peacemakers so and then the
peacemakers is a group that fights for
justice I texted Bart Bart Adam Miller
because people are making these
peacemakers reference to him yeah mr.
Graham yeah he goes who told you about
yeah I started seeing all over the place
all over the comments and I'm like
peacemakers I'm like how do people know
about this this is crazy
well I like I let the cat out in a bag
man but I I thought it was cool so the
peacemakers is a group that like goes
and goes to parties and you guys act
like security right well this is what I
remember what he asked for
and then and if a fight breaks out like
they fight because it's like you
shouldn't be fighting at a party beat up
the guys that started the fight but it
was like their excuse to fight but like
for justice and I thought it was the
most honorable cool
thing on earth because I do like fight
for like a gang or like do stupid [ __ ]
you know yeah I'm like wow you don't
have to fight for a gang like you can
fight for like security purposes that's
tight
yeah so how did you how did you come up
with the peacemakers so uh I didn't even
start it my best friend at the time his
name was Chris he and this one other
Japanese dude they started it and I was
Korean by the way of course another
Japanese Korean pair they started it and
at that time I just joined the group -
huh here's a Japanese guy was it Ryan
Mike Oh Mike yeah Oh crazy you know
Mike's like the Mike's the social guy so
we either had this buddy his name's Mike
and he's the kite the type of dude like
if we go to a club he'll be like be
right back he comes back with like eight
beers like one between every single
finger you get one you get didn't even
ask people am i Mike I'm not even trying
to drink tonight too bad and everyone
gets a beer he's that he's dad dude
where's Eve and I know he's a Japanese
Mike yeah but he's super friendly like
he's the type of dude where like if you
if you let him borrow like a dollar
he'll let you borrow a hundred bucks
he was just super nice so him and Chris
they were good buddies they linked up
and I think Chris was the one that
started it off with because it's based
off of a Bible verse which is like
blessed are the peacemakers or something
like children of God or something like
that so it started off like that and
then they wanted to do like righteous
like noble stuff and then when I joined
the group that's when I just finished I
stopped slinging ecstasy okay okay how
much hard as I changed my life this is
my second senior year in high school I
really got to make it right because you
don't spend five years in high school
but I was about to and I joined this
group and I was lost unlike game banging
I was done slaying in and I was I'm
gonna join this group and be friends
with them and then so they included me
and I remember we would meet at this
park and a Monterey Park called Sequoia
so it's up in the hills and we would all
like smoke cigarettes I had like
brainstorm the things that we should be
doing we're like a bunch of sixteen
seventeen year olds like brainstorm like
okay what
different ways that we can like make
this group better nor like oh we should
make pamphlets and like pass it around
the neighborhood to like to bring up
more membership and how many people
contacted you with the pamphlet nobody
exactly so they didn't start off as a
fight-fight crew right I think I brought
that in originally like like a
fraternity or like something you got
together and you did community service
or what was it so what they got together
cuz like you know how like at more
Keppel at the time it was like like the
cliques are either gangs or like Jah
yeah or like like geeks or like ASB yeah
and then there's a lot of just regular
people and they didn't really feel like
they had a belonging so like the people
that went raving or the people that
smoked cigarettes like there's just a
bunch of gray area people so I think
they wanted to create a group that like
just gray area people can identify with
and yeah hang out with just most of the
people like most of the people I knew
smoked cigarettes too so it was like it
was just a group for that and then you
know just people that like to go raving
and partying but they're like let's try
to make it like an honourable way of
like raving so like that sounds just
like a group of crackheads dude we gotta
keep the peace around here hold on let
me make some pants no for sure there's
uh there's definitely elements of like
you know like like Friday nights at
church uh-huh there's definitely
elements of like church there's elements
of barbecuing there's elements of
cigarette smoking and then there's
definitely elements of like street
racing because we'll be like okay cool
let's go pass out pamphlets and we're
driving like 90 miles per hour through
residential streets but like cars that
have like full exhaust and [ __ ]
just driving everywhere and then when I
know when I joined the group I was like
oh man like we can't be having like
throwing down at school that's not right
we got a if people got beef they got a
deal to like squash the beef in a safe
manner and then so we used to meet
before school on this street called
Hershey Avenue right next to the school
and when that's when I set up the Fight
Club oh you two got beef we got to
settle it on Hershey
and then so what if they were just like
we just want to talk it out nah homie
and if you don't show up we will [ __ ]
you guys we're making peace and then we
started having uh I think it went from
people having conflict throwing down to
people actually setting up fights now
and we would set up fights and there'd
be like like give people a different
handicap well this guy's way to break in
the new so that guy gets the gloves and
then we would have fights like almost
every day so what okay so turn into a
Fight Club we turned into like a Fight
Club on that Street I just imagine
myself as a parent and I have a kid like
you and then I'm asking you what you did
and I set you down and I'm like you
haven't been home in two weeks what have
you been doing and I want you to be
honest with you changing the world and
I'll be like listen this with me and
I've been changing the world dad okay
we're gonna we're gonna do this scenario
I'm your parent okay that's what most
parents do Bart I know you have been in
the house for a couple of weeks now and
I I want you to be honest with me what
you've been doing and trust me you won't
get in trouble I just want to know where
where you've been and what you've been
doing and I guarantee you I won't yell I
won't get mad just let me know what
you've been doing I've been doing
something more important than school and
that's changing the world which is what
which is we're gaining people together
and settling our differences outside of
school we won't get in trouble
how have you been doing there that
sounds good we've been smoking
cigarettes like one of the club things
to do is like let's get together and
smoke cigarettes like that's what it was
in high school it's such a hot commodity
that is has the pack yeah everyone bums
one yeah and it's [ __ ] gone and then
you're like [ __ ] who's gonna buy the
next one it was like that's true it was
like gold in high school yeah could you
two understand the premise of or
something that you created you decided
that you wanted to clean up your life
stop getting into five stop drugs so
instead you just decided to create a
group in order to fight people to get
people to stop
fighting yeah and then based off a Bible
verse yeah we had a good time though
like we had we started throwing parties
all the time people would eat people I
know and then I would relapse and it's
also an ecstasy at the parties again and
then when I was on I remember this one
time where I was I was selling and then
I started getting on ecstasy and then
one of my homies older brothers friends
found out he had ecstasy and then saw he
wanted some so I gave him some and I
remember like I was at the Christmas
house and I was just rolled and all that
but I just couldn't stop although you
think I'm taking in I'm selling out I'm
selling I'm taking it I like bad when
you when you were doing II what was what
was like your main driving reason for it
because you seem to have done it in
excess compared to everybody else yeah
yeah yeah it was like my favor like once
I got my hands on I think it just if
there's a sense of euphoria that you
feel in the sense of connection like you
could meet anybody off the street and
you guys become best friends I don't
know we're family yeah yeah you because
you turn it's a family like oh we're you
know one of one of my friends growing up
he started doing he's super young right
and it was just he was just like
hardcore into raves yeah
but he's very um obviously he's my
friend now but I actually saw him in
Sacramento not too long ago and he's
kind of um and it started he started
behaving this way after he started
tapering off when he was like 20
but his like emotionally he's kind of
like pretty blank you know you know I
mean I don't know what did to him I'm
not sure if it was even when did you
mean when did you see him again was it
like a years - after I don't know when
he stopped but then I he was friends
from by 14 all the way till high school
he can go to my school I actually met
him through church at [ __ ] yeah it
makes sense now I met the church but I
met him when in its 20s and then when I
met him again he was just like he didn't
he couldn't a moat that's possible I
remember uh like probably four three
years after I quit I was probably in
extreme depression like you're just
super melancholy cuz I think you fried
all of your serotonin receptors yeah to
the point where I like if
my mom bought me a brand new car or if
like I won the lottery or anything I'll
just buy oh that's pretty cool yeah I
mean what he does is mmm there's this
chemical in your brain called serotonin
yeah and that's supposed to be the happy
chemical so anytime you feel joy you get
excited you feel happy toward anything
that's the serotonin so what it does is
it gives you like an overdose of
serotonin so then your body's like
highly sensitive to everything makes you
happy and positive and all that but what
ends up happening is like your body can
produce only so much and it depletes and
then your body gets used to this normal
rate of high intense serotonin so like
when you when you don't have the E in
your body or whatever your body's
relying on that to create that feeling
and when you don't have it you crash
hard so it's like a caffeine you know
let me drink a lot of caffeine you're on
this high and if you have this crash
right cuz your body's so used to that
energy then it's like oh [ __ ] where did
it go
yeah it's like when you eat chocolate
and you know coke tastes like water yeah
yeah it's like that it's like once
you've experienced that then any other
technically quote-unquote happy stimulus
doesn't really make you happy yeah but I
mean it's possible that you can be
gained back that balance it just takes
time to recover it took me like probably
three years yeah good dan that's a long
[ __ ] time dude yeah did you just feel
weird like you just didn't feel like
yourself um well at that time when I
graduated high school I thought it was
just like oh I'm turning into an adult
so I didn't even back then like maybe
connected yeah I meant to help me I'm
really a thing so I just thought like oh
wait I'm turning into a boring [ __ ] like
my dad oh my okay I guess it's probably
was a shading grace then if you think
about it that you were able to
rationalize it as you just becoming an
adult versus you kind of pinning the
reason why you are the way you are on
this drug because you know when you're
young mentally you're very weak yeah and
if you could find a reason to blame yeah
your current state and how you're at
with from a product yeah I felt like
that pot would have [ __ ] you up but
that might have been your saving grace
it could have been just by me being
ignorant - yeah like not knowing that it
fried my brain so I was just like oh I'm
turning into a boring adult then when
did you start feeling like oh [ __ ] like
I'm happy again um I think
I think once I started like like doing
MMA hanging out with Joe and like having
friends and then like getting I was like
just college right yeah yeah like
getting back into it I feel like my
first two or three years of college I
think finally I was like starting to
feel happiness again I didn't hang out
with this guy until like I was 19 or
something hmm
so have you wait wait so in high school
in 23 maybe well 21 or 22 really well I
think I met you because that's when I we
did shoumaine stuff nah yeah so I uh
oh yeah yeah damn dude so we started JK
at 2300 at the DVDs in 2005 yeah so we
have this fight I was talking about we
used to be far so so going back in
history during all of this when when
what bar was going through I didn't know
him but we I knew the people that he's
talking about cuz I went to raves with
them or whatever like I I knew this like
I knew Mike I knew Chris but I was
getting deeper into like gang [ __ ] yeah
so while he was trying to better himself
and and wait did you go to the military
yet I went to the military in 2003 so
after that you graduated you went to the
military Yeah right so I went the other
way and got into worse crimes worse
bigger drug deals things like that and
then a bunch of my friends went to jail
I mean you know you know some of them
some of them we do business with yeah
and all that um legal legal business
with legal business yeah yeah
I mean well he actually came out with it
so it's basically Jeremy also like
blossom yeah so a lot of us went when
and that was like a big shot like oh
[ __ ] like [ __ ] is real yeah you know
there was a drive-by in front of our
friend's house like and as I was going
to my friend's house you know that guy
got killed and if I was there five
minutes earlier in the front door and
the patio I would have been I would have
been shot at - that's just [ __ ] crazy
yeah so so reality kind of hit me and
then that's when I was like alright time
to kind of like be better I guess yeah
but that's when I met these guys and
then same guy Chris like I think I think
he had a lot of passion in trying to I
guess rehabilitator or change the world
you know and then I
just hanging out with these guys I was
like oh there is a different option out
there you know and and you can still
enjoy bad things but you can be kind of
good in a good way still smoke
cigarettes yeah we could still fight
smoke cigarettes and whatever but that's
that's when he invited me to go to the
MMA gym and then that's when I when I
met this dude in and we were like 18 9
19 maybe 19 20 PQR ple be talkin bout
purple yeah this podcast is brought to
you by purple my friends if you let me
say something if you don't know about
purple the number one you must be out of
your mind because I love my purple
mattress not even as a joke I'm full
real Z for real Z because it definitely
solved the problem that I had before
when I had my other mattress it's like
number one for some reason all my other
mattresses they would make me hot hot as
heck my friends and I'm telling you
right now
purple somehow manages to always stay
cold there's some kind of technology in
there and I will tell you what I bet you
didn't know this that purple was
actually created by a rocket scientist
I'm talking about their science behind
this there's science to making a
mattress somehow soft yet firm at the
same time we're talking about the story
of porridge my friends is the porridge
too hot is the poor's too cold guess
what no it's purple baby that's what's
up so check this out
hahahahahaha so you are going to love
purple and right now my listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four - eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is detects
brain - eight four - eight eight eight
that's B R a I n two eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply this makers is technically it's
still in on brand without JK films is
though you know it's like eating good
things no teaching cook that wasn't
around during the Peacekeeper thing you
know but he would he would tell me about
the times when you guys would go to the
parties and you would fight in
there's just like a DVD clip to this
would like go to like frat like frat
parties and clubs and stuff and look at
people that look like they could be
belligerent and troublemakers and then
we would start [ __ ] with them first to
get into a fight in our mind or like oh
that's what looks like he's trying to
start some [ __ ] we would go and start
[ __ ] with baby did someone like break a
bottle on someone's head and had to like
leave the whole party yeah but that
wasn't uh that was a peacemaker
that wasn't a peacemaker event okay like
that is not peacemaker but behavior you
need a peacemaker no so like we would
just hang out so like me we that that
particular event we went to a fourth of
July block party in Temple City and it
was Chris's older brother he was in a
Cal State LA type of Asian Union Club
yeah so he got invited to this big-ass
block party on the street it's one of
those were like people's grills are on
their front lawn like everyone's
partying in this cul-de-sac and then so
the peacemakers go there you know try to
get more members and stuff and then I
remember we're just hanging out there it
had recruiting to what I'd always talk
to be a family block party you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude so we're playing
we're playing
I mean we're lighting fireworks uh-huh
and then I was just drinking and then my
go-to rule is after I empty my first
bottle that's always my weapon so he's
out in my pocket so if my empty Corona
and then my second one I throw away but
I always have something just in case
[ __ ] happens cuz I got to keep the peace
and then there's this dude this one that
random dude kept lighting these
fireworks and throwing out my homie
Chris and then would go and explode yeah
I know
and Chris would turn around Mike what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and then so I
went to mama hey can you stop doing that
and he goes who [ __ ] are you anymore
people like step no you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah and I'm like hey can you
please stop doing that he goes or what
and I was just like
[ __ ] smashing on his head and then
that will drop to the ground and then it
just all hell broke loose yeah people
just started knocking people out of
[ __ ] nowhere and then what the [ __ ]
happening and then will I perish bye
girls and then we bounced probably three
people died that day as somebody who the
[ __ ] are the peacemakers there's no
peace at this party we were a dozen
family event we were dumb we block boy
that's a family block party I know we I
don't know we were really dumb it made
sense at the time what we're trying to
do who did you know it the family the
block party so are my best friends older
brother he in his club someone lived
there oh so I mean everyone was like
probably 19 20 25 like everyone was
older then I should escalate it due to
his size what the [ __ ] are you gonna do
Oh simple when you're 19 and someone
tells you that it's like oh now I have
to do something yeah yeah I mean like
coming from our generation like like we
know is like gang that's when I look at
these comments and I just see people
bickering back and forth I'm like what
are you guys talking about so Duke it
out yeah cuz back in our day it was
people the you they probably only step
to each other once or twice and I was
full [ __ ] blown yeah yeah people
don't really like talk that much yeah if
I knew someone could [ __ ] my ass up I
wouldn't I wouldn't even I try not to
dislike somebody I'm gonna have to fight
him yeah and I'm like I'm just gonna
keep the peace [ __ ] that's a peacemaker
you are the other have somebody
different well that's different if you
if you I don't know it's it's different
like especially if you're getting
bullied right you're trying to burn my
friend it was a little firework as we're
the liquid you're younger and you think
about it in retrospect I think that's an
adult that somebody did that use what
the [ __ ] I just walk away you know but
while you're younger every it's an ego
check yeah oh [ __ ] this guy's trying to
test my ego make me look like a [ __ ] in
front of all these people yeah so I'm
gonna [ __ ] him up that's like the first
thing that pops in your head
you know how stupid we were dude there's
some nights we get together it's like
Friday night we don't know what to do so
I'm like hey and we should try to figure
out there is like some crime we can
solve oh my god so we'll start like
texting everybody what sorry
texting people and we're just going out
on a list we just sit there I'm a young
anything bad happen anyone anything uh
anything get jacked or whatever and I
remember this one time we barely knew
this girl but it was like like a
friend's like Tom sings Tom sing yeah
and I think we word got out that her
boyfriend like sexually assaulted her or
so we don't even know if it we just
jumped on it we're like where is this in
Fulton high we're all like oh this seems
like a job for the peacemakers didn't
even get the full story part it doesn't
matter which we have we drove five cars
deep and then we jumped these two
brothers and then later on I found out
that I don't even know if it was true
that she got raped or not there was like
these to do just got beat up for no
reason [ __ ] their [ __ ] praise band
worship hey kick their ass I don't I
mean I don't really know but it was just
we were just like hey everything okay
when we just try to like fish out some
crime through our phones they're just
guilty there's no judgement it's just I
thought the e was supposed to make you
happy what the [ __ ] that's what happens
in quickie yeah some type of excitement
let's just start beating up innocent
people it's time for the peacemakers
dude wrong [ __ ] name your name should
be looking for trouble done man or
somebody it's like they figure out a way
to justify because they still want to
get into action but they want to be like
they want to not feel guilty about it
there are definitely some people who
just like fighting though like yeah
we're just the right yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] fighting and I don't know what
it is like that makes me I wonder if
it's like an environment thing people
who are you I never liked fighting but I
always got into some I just saw Chloe
you [ __ ] need a [ __ ] out of
somebody's face but I don't like
fighting this is DVD clip just to bring
it back to that of the are we gonna
watch it oh we can't watch it on okay
okay but there's maybe you could put
beer all over well show you we'll put
but there's literally a video of just
Bart and Joe with these [ __ ] helmets
on at this karate MMA place just going
buck wild on people dude you guys are
[ __ ] number one so there's a clip of
him beating up one of his friends I'm
talking about Bart gets sidemount and he
just starts pummeling this whole space
multiple times all yours
did you [ __ ] full mouth did you start
helping him in the [ __ ] face I know I
felt bad it was cuz uh earlier that day
I fought this other dude named ash yeah
and um I didn't fight smart I fought
emotionally so I made a lot of mistakes
and I think when I sat back down I was
like [ __ ] can't believe I got [ __ ] up
and so when I fought my buddy Ryan I
think I ended up taking it all out on
them and I felt so bad I dig you kill
them you know in the size difference
like Ryan is like five five everybody's
like a larger in pounds
I think weirdest thing that I saw on the
DVD was that everybody was not anywhere
near the same size or no hole guys were
fighting girls are just crazy that [ __ ]
was insane there was no such thing as
weight class at our at our dojo the guy
that you were finding was almost similar
size oh yeah she crapped the back of his
neck I just need his face to another
universe and then you grab his neck
again you need him in the stomach like
six times I didn't make good contact or
else he would have been knocked out but
the helmet saved them a lot screw these
are strong was he very strong cuz you
guys were punching the [ __ ] out of each
other's face yeah I mean though the
place we went to was a full-contact like
mmm a martial art place but it has a
huge emphasis in karate and jujitsu just
to put it in perspective when they say
full-contact MMA gym and they're talking
about MMA gloves up it's just a sock it
is literally just a tube sock it's like
a sock with like a maxi pad yeah it's
really thin it does nothing yeah when
you were a fighting man dude ash one of
your [ __ ] came off yeah yeah it just
flew right off what kind of [ __ ] is that
it's not even MMA club during our
training so many times the whole thing
would just rotate all the way around
yeah and by the time you're done like
the gloves not even on your hand or what
it would do is it will go all it will
hike up all the way to your hand and
your knuckles are exposed so I still
have scars
this day because the mask it's like a
cheese grater so like the map it's like
a plastic mask and the holes there's
holes like for breathing but it
literally looks like a cheese grater so
like when you're punching it in your
hand scrapes it it it basically peels
the skin out yeah it was [ __ ] sad how
did you guys find that find that place I
don't well I got invited by our buddy
oh you got invited by Chris yeah that's
how I that's all i learned about it
because he was like oh do you like
karate and stuff and I'm like I did as a
kid and I want to get back into it so he
invited me and then you know sensei was
cool as hell our sensei at the time was
like in his 30s he was young he was like
so it was like it didn't feel like oh
this is like lame and old like this
guy's cool you know and then we all
train together and I was like hell yeah
this ain't fake karate like everyone
gets to fight here yeah I think we
arrived at it I thought you found your
own way there no no it was you he was he
was recruiting man like he was trying to
get people to go so I went and I just
loved it I was like oh this is so cool
because like most karate is not full
contact it's soft contact and there's a
lot of emphasis on like kata or forms
yeah and this is just straight brawler
style yeah like this is a hard knockdown
style karate and MMA right you know his
ground game yeah yeah and everything but
our sensei his background is like it's
like a karate I think he did Taekwondo
he's got like black belts in like three
four martial arts he did jiu-jitsu judo
like and then he created his own style
of MMA we me and Chris found it cuz we
used to go up and down the street
challenging dojos so we would go we
would know is wrong with you how why
would you just start challenging they
don't it's ancient China we wanted to
see like a legit place so we go to a
place you know it's a like I don't know
like whatever karate or Taekwondo or
whatever you know blah hey can we fight
one of your black belts and the most the
place would be like no no kick or not
gonna train here and then we knew this
place was the place cuz we're like hey
sensei oh no we went through my can we
find one of her black belts and he goes
how about this I'll do you better and
then they played he played
of the belt tests because this is how we
belt test and he just played on the the
TV and then me and Chris looked at it
we're like oh [ __ ] this place is legit
and so we just signed up right then and
there and keep in mind to back then MMA
existed like UFC all that existed but it
was really difficult to find like yeah
yeah that's all look for yeah I don't
look for its either it's the closest
thing you got was kickboxing or Muay
Thai but even some of the because during
that time - well this is definitely
obviously when did I go to Riverside
that was what six oh five or six so we
were we were training in like 2004
around the same time like even the
kickboxing that I took you there was
there wasn't just enough knowledge right
so anybody
it was during their cuz every martial
art had a weird time or when it was
bustling and it was doing really well
the credentials really weren't there so
anybody could say that they were this
degree this type of black belt so even
the muy Thai gym I went to sucked and I
wouldn't have known until I started
taking my weight again yeah everything
was all [ __ ] up and I was like okay so
that [ __ ] took my money you know
I didn't learn anything yeah cuz all I
did was take it forward he goes oh I
know I trained in Thailand you know did
all this other [ __ ] and you know what
that means exactly yeah you kind of
learn all this other stuff and really
what I learned was cardio kickboxing I
had no [ __ ] idea yeah you know we
started training with Nick and I was
like oh I don't know anything yeah I
thought I did I was like oh this is
gonna be easy but it wasn't it was so
different and it's weird because when I
was sick watching you guys fight I was
caught as a prize house you guys were
standing so straight up so I don't
understand what could you said he was a
karate but it skill question more yeah I
mean if you watch coaching fights like
he's just two guys I kind of walk up to
each other and square up and start
drawing it's just all so we weren't that
good in general so he taught us some
stuff that were real but it's just I
think being that young and like learning
so slow and not knowing a lot of [ __ ]
like we were making a lot of horrible
mistakes yeah we were white belts at at
his school I got that low oh so that's
what white belts do white belts doing a
lot of spar and Taekwondo yeah no that
was the white though and then the two
the two brown belt
that were there they fought and came in
the cage so they were pro so like
whatever a system that sensei taught him
was good enough for them to fight and
kill me yeah the brown belts look good
they did Muay Thai fights at the Valdez
like my success because I know like in
even when we did Taekwondo and a we in
our place too we had a couple of people
that went to the Olympics so they even
when you're a white belt you're not even
allowed to spar yeah like you're just
taught technique and a lot of yeah I
mean same with me now I do shotokan
karate yeah and unless you're a brown
belt and above you can't even spar yeah
but the type of sparring too it's like
it's it's it's so there's a difference
between soft contact or no contact yeah
and in knockdown or full contact yeah
right so like most sparring in the soft
contact
it's like point fighting so once you tag
you're not trying to kick the living
[ __ ] out of your partner right you're
just trying to snap it real quick but
you're supposed to have control yeah and
then that's a point and then they
there's a lot of I think it's more
subjective right because you know like
let's say I mean you're obviously bigger
than me right so like it might take me
more you know hits to get you down but
technically in the sport if I if I make
a point that's considered a knockout
oh and then you move on right but then
in reality so that's where coaching came
to be mas oyama he studied shotokan
karate and when he watched that he was
like man this is not like it's not a
practical yeah yeah he's like the only
way to test your skill is to really
fight so then that's where this
philosophy came to be and then so like
the not in a knockdown style karate you
you have it's like it's like boxing
right you either get knocked out or you
don't
mmm and then you do get points but they
look at like the the damage the hits
that you protect yourself all this guy
like I think that's one of the bigger
reasons why the tech won no place that I
went to when I was a kid went under
because a lot of our stuff cuz I saw
Olympic Taekwondo like how it evolved
and it was just like it's like touch but
to me you know me yeah yeah yeah in our
tech window [ __ ] we would beat the [ __ ]
out of each other it was like kicks for
kicks for kicks people get heel kicked
in the face people got psychic like my
my first time I ever sparked without a
little kid I just never I just sock the
kid in the face I got trouble for that
but there were times where like I was
allowed I want back straight that Cape a
kid so hard in his stomach he threw up
but that was normal you know yeah it
wasn't like you get to tap and you go
yeah yeah like if you psychic somebody
it hurt yeah but we had the shield and
everything Oh yet the body with the red
dots on it yeah so we had the body
shield and stuff yeah but then we had
full-on contact we were allowed to go
ham we just couldn't use our hands nice
there's a video like I mean there's
footage on YouTube you could see old
school Taekwondo versus new school yeah
and what you're talking about it's like
you'll see the difference in how softer
it's become yeah cuz I I think that's
why I understand why maybe our place
didn't do as well as some of the other
dojos to hardcore it was way too
hardcore because we would do our our pom
says right and if it was off he had that
bamboo kendo stick and he would hit us
bop my hat's too old-school yeah so
that's how he did it but then everybody
in our team kicked ass at these
tournaments they would [ __ ] people up
while they're crying inside yeah but we
would [ __ ] people up I think it's just
because of how strict he was it was so
[ __ ] strict but I mean there was a
lot of bad people in class but I when we
saw the level of competition that we
would face we just were a lot better we
get kicked our ass kicked just when we
were trained which is kind of cool yeah
I mean this was pretty hardcore I think
there's a similar belt testing in
coaching but the only way to rank up is
to do full contact fights so the video
that you watched is our belt testing so
in our school it was like you get white
belt and then there's like five stripes
right was it five stripes or something I
was like three oh three stripes yeah and
then you get brown belt yeah so each
stripe represents an opponent so they
let's say you're doing your first
stripes testing you just have to last
three minutes with them you can't be
submitted or else you don't get your
stripe right yeah and then so for your
second stripe it's two consecutive so
like three minute round and then you
break and then three minute round yeah
and then four three so on but then for
your brown belt I think it's five
consecutive mmm and then for your black
but I think it's ten yes ten straight
people yeah what is and that's
basically coaching karate testing rules
- I think it's it's it's like each rank
its consecutive fights so by the time
you hit black belt I think it's you have
ten opponents that are they're supposed
to be fresh opponents and then it's back
to back that's [ __ ] critical so when
you guys met each other at the MMA thing
were you guys like instant friends is
that one of those things where it
clicked or you guys develop a
relationship over time
I didn't develop over time I mean we
were all friends cuz you working on one
person yeah yeah hang out like
afterwards we'd go eat at like JJ's or
something or yeah there's another one
actually old-school one that we scored I
think it's called Sunday cafe yeah yeah
Sunday that they turned into Sunday
Bistro yeah yeah it was like it was on
Atlantic and they tore down that place
and then they moved but like we used to
have threes to be for more cafes in
there than they are now and the days are
still around yeah yeah okay we haven't
been there in a long time kind of a mush
because before that I remember Vince
went there and he told me that they're
kind of pricey what if they were still
around cuz that [ __ ] used to be our
cheap quick bite yeah yeah maybe cuz
they upgraded they think they're bougie
now yeah or maybe just everybody else
like anymore yeah but when you guys had
that hole so wait do you guys still hang
out with the people that you hung out
with before that you met together with
that um I just started talking you know
with Ryan now Ryan again oh that's right
Ryan is a fascinating character yeah
Ryan is a fire professed uh fost [ __ ]
nails deer days a tough [ __ ]
yeah so this little Bart he brought this
guy Ryan over to train with us this is
really funny [ __ ] moment
so everybody has [ __ ] guards but nobody
Brian doesn't have [ __ ] guards and the
what rollers if you don't have a shin
guard no [ __ ] kicks so they're gonna
put it on him a little bit yeah okay
well cut the [ __ ] this guy yeah yeah I
mean it he made it to brown belt young
yes he was about to be brown though oh
he's about to be he's [ __ ] tough dude
nice a tough dude even watching him spar
you he was getting his ass beat but he
was still in it yeah he's he's an
adrenaline junkie yeah I mean like he's
done a couple tours in
he's a marine like oh holy [ __ ] he's you
know a sheriff like he put he
specifically looked to patrol the the
Lord's neighbor yeah
why yeah cuz I don't know I think he
went to Compton and he did a ride-along
there and he was like oh I like this and
then so he was well starting to drop it
and bombs everywhere let's start some
[ __ ] no no he's he's a yeah he says that
because of his size like he has to be
smart in the way that he police's
because he's he's like five four this
guy he's not big you know like and and
you know he he just says that there's a
lot of mental gymnastics like a lot of
politics and and and just outsmarting
his you know guys and stuff like that
cuz he's like there's no way he can
intimidate them I think it's smart for
people I think all cops should learn
some form of do Jitsu oh yeah I think
they should at least get up to a high
level Bluebell I think all chicks should
oh yeah
just that's a good self-defense measure
because you can neutralize size it can
neutralize strength yeah
and unlike striking whether it's like
there's a lot of chance like even if I
fought Mike Tyson that I could just
close my eyes and randomly knock him out
there's a possibility but in jiu-jitsu
it's such a chess match that it's it's
almost impossible to have a lucky
submission yeah if you went for a
submission that means you actually went
for it and you set that up you can't get
like a lucky Kimura on someone you know
yeah yeah it's just one of those things
says I'm so surprised when I watch you
know we watch videos of police officers
trying to take down a subject yeah but
they can't do it it's like dude if they
just took like a year or two of
jiu-jitsu
yeah how fast would they be able to
neutralize this person way easily way
easier all the cops in Japan know
jujitsu judo same thing oh really
there's videos of them like so a lot of
them look you know you know the cops in
Asia that they look they look like you
could [ __ ] them up yeah right and then
there was this like big six-foot black
guy like that was like I think he was
like on your drunk or something right
and in and in it it was like you know
that show cops yep but it was like in
Japan hmm
and you just see like 10 Japanese cops
like like
trying to surround them and this guy's
like he's grabbing like you know things
from a construction like like being
throwing it at them like they're
outdoorsy let me show ya he was like he
was like [ __ ] launching fists like it
was like oh [ __ ] what we gonna do right
and so one cop kind of like distracted
him and then the other guy who just went
down and tackled his legs and then like
busted some judo [ __ ] got him on the
ground and they all pile on top of them
like a bunch of ants what yeah that's
crazy no I always yeah it's just weird
cuz yeah self-defense - I think a lot of
people don't find it like it's necessary
you know what I mean yeah but then I
think like when you recorded like these
weird situations you just never [ __ ]
know well it depends on like your world
like where did you grow up
mmm you know like I think we both have
we all have PTSD yeah cuz no one
experiences like walking down the street
and somebody just yelling at you and
throwing a bottle at you or whatever
[ __ ] and I we have so many stories like
that yeah where you're just chilling and
minding your own business and a car full
of guys just pull up and then run up to
you and start hassling you harassing you
or someone just wants to have fun and
punch you or whatever yeah I mean that's
I hated that [ __ ] dude it was so [ __ ]
you couldn't wear certain things yeah
yeah you had to be very careful of like
just how you were as a person like it's
so stupid
I just [ __ ] hated that [ __ ] and you
know it was a [ __ ] nice kid so just
suck I'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
right so we we have in the back of our
minds like oh it's real the threat is
real we could be a victim any day yeah
cuz we've been victims right so that
makes you kind of like worried that it's
gonna happen again so I don't know like
other people that grew up differently
from us like I always hear this they'll
be like why do people need a gun why do
people need to even protect themselves
like it's not the Wild West anymore or
like it usually comes from people that
just never seen danger what I like about
knowing self-defense though I think
there's like this level of confidence
that's inside where like when you know
like let's say if you're a blue belt or
whatever right you know you can take out
90% of the world then I think it reduces
your stress level yeah when you're at
the bar or even at Vegas and you see two
dudes look what
woody to us a bro like when you you can
tell it's too insecure dudes yeah just
trying to like out chest puff each other
it's like two peacocks yeah but if you
know you can kick someone's ass it's
like hey just calm down like when you
see any time like a UFC fighter get into
an altercation and they catch you like
worldstar style it's always them hey
just relax it's not a big deal because
they know if I want to fight this floor
I will kill him yeah yeah and I think it
just it would just reduce people stress
and like an C level if everyone just
took a little bit that's true because
when guys are like drunk and and trying
to show off like they're always taking
off their it's a spectacle but like when
people are actually going to attack or
fight like it's never like that I think
if somebody try to take off their shirt
if they're trying to fight me
immediately right when it goes above
their face I'm throwing [ __ ] yeah I
think balls is smashing I would just
grab that shirt when it's on there and
just start people are [ __ ] extra I
mean cuz you you don't go out as much
anymore obviously you have a kid yeah
you know and everything you know you you
just have so many businesses but but now
it's cool cuz now that I know like if
someone wants to [ __ ] with Tiger like
like I've only just been taking like
kickboxing for about a year and a half
now but I can confidently say I could
probably kick like 70% of people's asses
you know so it's cool to like know that
if I need to protect Tiger that could
happen it's interesting because I think
it's as we get as we've gotten older to
because we don't go out as much yeah
we're away from a lot of those
situations but every time without fail
if I go to a club or a bar because of
number one like a college show or some
friends are in town and they want to go
it it's always there there's always some
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] that once
thought like it's a hundred percent of
the time it's going to [ __ ] happen so
it's about whether you go to that
situation or not now I just refuse to go
to open like crazy bars that's why I
hate clubs man it's annoying
everyone's trying I like I don't even
one try to [ __ ] you're a fight you there
was a when I had a I had a cousin that
came through and she wanted to go to
like a popping club out in k-town so we
took her out k-town and I literally just
stood in line for a quick second and you
just see a bunch of dudes staring at you
and I'm like I'm out of here this is
dumb it makes me feel unsafe I feel like
maybe that's why I only like it when I
go overseas or somewhere different yeah
like if if
like I don't know we were in Malaysia
and then I was like yeah let's go and it
was fun yeah I never witnessed gangster
David Choi for her any gangster David
Choi stories dude I know I know a crazy
David Choi story did but I get one of
the funniest [ __ ] thing I don't even
sure if he [ __ ] remembers but then at
the same time I think so it's so funny
because in in a stand-up set oh [ __ ]
Popo baby
but in a stand-up set I wanted to tell
this David Choi story yeah number one if
you guys don't know david choi
davidchoimusic in the last month and
he's [ __ ] real as [ __ ] yeah out of
all the youtubers that I've met that I
thought would have been really well kept
together this fool is a disaster awesome
is his persona is like squeaky clean and
I just play this folk when he is
restrained uh yeah this full one you
know I might just tell the story anyways
and if David if you want me to take this
down I'm still not gonna do it so so
this is one time we were out in k-town
right and mind you like David is a funny
[ __ ] dude I love every time I see
this did I get really happy but David
was a little blast that you know Korean
people we drink everybody has fun yeah
but as we're at k-town we're walking by
right and there's his girl growing this
flannel shirt we're next to her
boyfriend and dave is walking now we're
all drunk and David goes what's up
flannel shirt and the do goes you know
some had you talking to my girl he goes
I [ __ ] you die this what David David it
goes from 0 to 100 he goes yeah I'm
talking to your girl [ __ ] we all stop
her like that's not right dude what the
[ __ ] I looks at everybody else and he
goes did he just call me a [ __ ] right
100 yeah and then David out of nowhere
unnecessary he goes I called you a [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my [ __ ] confused and he goes
what do I do
he goes yo did you forget call me a
[ __ ] again right the dude is like and
then you know Abe Abe comes up he just
kind of grabs David away and if it's
like 5 3 2 by the way
feistiest [ __ ] and it's always the short
guys that get everybody else in trouble
dude and then Abe kind of grass him
Vecchio's yo calm down and as David's in
a dist
he still goes he still somehow managed
to squeeze what's up [ __ ] the distance
and this do gets [ __ ] angry he's
getting mad now he goes do I'm a [ __ ]
your friend and his girl was trying to
calm him down or whatever he should have
done it earlier [ __ ] a brawls about to
go out and I [ __ ] you not one of his
friends come comes in the guy's friend
comes up and he goes yo yo yo chill
chill chill chill chill cool cool cool
is whatever his cool is cool
he tries to squash the beef and as he
squashes the beef he comes at Davey goes
dude David
y'all I'm a big family yo can I get a
picture selfie with David he takes his
[ __ ] friend away David [ __ ] wild
dude damn yeah he's lucky that guy
wasn't crazy you know I think I think he
would have got swung at if it just
didn't come out out of nowhere and it
was so funny it was kind of funny
because it was so unnecessary yeah you
do because David was in the wrong he was
like any other dudes girlfriend I just
walking next to him I don't know where
he just goes yeah oh yes it was such a
girl [ __ ] yeah she'd throw me off to
David's [ __ ] funny man do you think
you know what what do you think about
all this like YouTube people call each
other off for fights and stuff
oh I mean definitely you could you you
already know people are doing it because
it's the hot thing to do
yeah I just think it's just a really
dumb thing to do because you're actually
gonna get hit yeah somebody's people
they're they're planning it out don't
like the recent one with [ __ ] they're
still doing them too there's a few other
kids that are gonna box that on YouTube
because I they are it makes money which
ones are they I don't know I saw
somebody training with Roy Roy Jones
Jones jr. it was another YouTube kid
that's gonna box or something how do
they have access to these people they
got money oh they got mad money you you
think these [ __ ] huge boxing stars
are gonna say no if they're gonna charge
him my four hundred five hundred bucks a
session yeah yeah they're not I'm saying
they don't give a [ __ ] they're just
gonna train them they are they're gonna
get their ass beat that's why I didn't
really care to watch the logan paul and
the ksi one just because i like boxing
as a sport yeah right I'm not there to
watch some low-level amateurs fight not
to say that they could have [ __ ]
somebody up for sure if they're just if
they're just in the middle of the street
those two will [ __ ] somebody up yeah but
if I'm trying to watch a boxing event
I'm not gonna watch too low-level
amateurs fight so don't you want to see
him get hit in the face I would want
them to get hit in the face with
somebody who can really do damage to
them oh you know what I mean because
those two weren't gonna do much damage
to each other
it's all planned that's what that's what
I want people to wail
on each other yeah like they hate each
other like I did I never saw that I mean
for sure with Logan Paul - I mean the
guy think the guy wrestled in high
school yeah that's what I heard yeah I
think he wrestled in high school and
he's a big dude man he's like a 6-3 or
some [ __ ] like that
yeah in that case I kids like tall to me
he's like six 162 or some [ __ ] but yeah
there's some big beefy dudes so if you
see them fight though they will crack
each other but when I saw a little clip
of them fight I was like this is the
worst fight I've ever seen in my life
it was just it wasn't entertaining if
someone challenged do you think he'll
fight them it depends on who it is it
depends on who it is and how long I plan
to train so also you would actually
entertain if idea if I could just boxing
or kickboxing or anything how do
kickboxing if I if I would I would do
kickboxing I have to know who it is we
have to be around the same weight we
would have to be the same weight we'll
do it by weight class and then on top
most likely you're heavier than them and
I would like to I would like to I need a
train though so I I would literally drop
it you know how my personality every
[ __ ] I would drop every move to Thailand
for two months it would have to be a
mature rule so we need headgear Shane
cards though Oh who would you like I
don't know well you don't even need a
train for that yeah as different but it
would it would be fun I mean I would
prefer to fight somebody that I like
though cuz I want it to be I want
competitive competitive you want to
fight someone you like or somebody that
I just don't have any emotions for I
want to fight someone I hate because if
I if you just buy somebody we hate we
they just meet up and just Duke it out
all right right you know yes knock on
the door we'll have some [ __ ] I'll take
a rock and I'll smash your face open
ghetto style yeah but if it piece makes
that yeah peace baby stuff but if it was
something where it was like competitive
it would be nice it would be somebody
that I could fight that I know like it
loves the sport as much as I love the
sport and then we could see where we go
from there and it would be kind of nice
to clash and see what happens
yeah um but number one I won't be able
to because Merida will never ever let me
and I think it's like she's so Marilyn
but people don't know about Muriel she
hates violence of any sort what if she'd
consider violence its football violence
to her she does my dad can't even watch
football Oh your dad doesn't watch ball
I mean I could watch MMA here and there
yeah but when she sees violence in the
like in front of her face she [ __ ]
hates it so when
we used to get into fights back in the
day like arguments and I would raise my
voice and yell it would actually like
like we'd scare her a bit because she
would see that a lot from her dad so her
dad you know just a Korean parent just
being really loud yeah breaking [ __ ] in
the house which is very Asian yeah she
hates seeing that [ __ ] so when she sees
that it actually scares her so if she
sees me even doing Muay Thai and then we
do something's too serious she [ __ ]
hates it doesn't want to see that side
of you she does like it either like she
when she when she saw me get super angry
once it almost made her want to break
the break-up and harsh so like that's
one of those things that I don't really
want to gamble with yeah yeah and even
if it's like okay well it's one thing
but for forever in the rest of her life
she will remember that one time I went
in and I got my face bashed in and it's
gonna [ __ ] with her head oh you got
another one were you in or or I would I
just knock the person now but you know
but you guys already know what it takes
to be a fighter and I don't know if I
had that it takes it takes a lot cuz
it's not even just the whole you know
drilling and training constantly getting
enough hands to get in into that ring to
fight
there's the conditioning part of it
right and after your conditioning you
gotta get proper sleep proper training
how many how many how many times are you
reviewing what you're doing it's just
cyclical over over and over and it's a
full-time job and even then you're still
not ready yeah time job cuz you're gonna
fight I want to I really want to but
it's a bucket list yeah it's a bucket
list name but then I keep going back and
forth like there's a side of me that's
like oh it's a bucket list thing you
really want to do it and then like and
it what I like about fighting it's kind
of like the culmination of everything I
like about athletics and sports like you
have to do anything addition you have to
run and do your roadwork you have to do
the drilling and the technique you have
to do the sparring and get the sparring
and like there's a lot of aspects that
you have to train and so I really like
that but then the other side I mean that
kind of scares me a little bit is like
there's all this head trauma people with
CTE oh for sure and then I'm like I'm a
business owner I'm a dad do I really
need to have CTE and trauma to the head
is that the smartest thing for me to do
just for a bucket list so I keep like
I'd probably debate myself like every
single day about it like if I once I get
it to jiu-jitsu judo Jiu Jitsu
tournaments for sure as a no-brainer
cuz you can go a hundred percent with
someone yeah and no one's gonna get hurt
but like in sparring like we can go say
50% and she'll get her and randomly
someone throws a thing or throws or
whatever and then yeah it is you're like
oh [ __ ] that really like jog my brain up
a little bit and I don't know if I need
that right now
the the whole fighting aspect to I think
it's it's become really glorified and
you know I think we've what I found out
to just training a lot there's a lot of
people who think they're good but
they're actually not they're not and
those are the ones you want to find yeah
they are not [ __ ] good and it's
pretty terrible so when I like I went to
[ __ ] spar at a different gym just
because this was when we first started
doing kickboxing with Nick and it was
just to have fun because my friend
invited me out so we went out and then
we were just doing light sparring but
there's even this thing of like people
when they lights bar everybody's
definition of light sparring is
different to this dude [ __ ] cracked
me in my [ __ ] jaw
am i doing no mouthpiece no nothing
there's usually guys with too much ego
yeah I don't like sparring outside of my
friends yeah because you know there's a
certain level of control and you know
the guy cracks me I get [ __ ] angry
and I just hack his leg with the [ __ ]
low kick I [ __ ] hacked his leg as
hard as I could and even that I didn't
feel good about it but what you know it
just it kind of escalates to a place
that you don't want it to go to yeah you
just never know I mean what if that guy
knocked out my teeth what if my mouth
was open and I clocked my teeth he
woulda knocked my teeth out yeah yeah I
know I don't like that [ __ ] it happens
you're gonna fight them what do you mean
you know for sure I don't for sure
you're gonna fight how do you know cuz I
feel like it's a buckle this thing and I
feel like you're gonna need to check
that off maybe I think you lost a fight
I did tell Ron who's my Muay Thai coach
I was like when I tell you I'm ready
just sign me up cuz I don't want to deal
with the anxiety cuz even with my
paladin teammates when I know what if
you're on we're gonna vacation or
something I don't know I just don't just
sit back out but like even with
powerlifting meets which is nonviolent
like when you have a big thing in front
of ya in or eight weeks out seven weeks
out six weeks out like you there's a lot
of anxiety that goes to it I don't
really like that feeling so the
anticipation right okay unknown yeah
yeah you so I'm like I don't even if I
do a fight I would just start doing my
roadwork start doing all that stuff once
I get my weight down and I feel good I'm
like hey Ron just sign me up anytime
could literally be here I signed you up
tomorrow and I'll do it I would feel
better to do that then I remember when
we had our belt test yeah I knew our
belt test was that weekend and that
whole week like my every time I thought
about it my heart was like well me was
the day before I was debated for yeah it
was like I'm not gonna jack off tonight
yeah that's my preparation I like the
energy yeah all mostly barley no video
game not gonna jack off and I was like
in bed tossing and turning from 10:00
p.m. till like 1:00
yeah I [ __ ] up cuz of that day I
draped like three Red Bulls oh and it's
a war was going [ __ ] crazy I mean
that's what I thought I need to get at
so I thought that I think that's why I
[ __ ] up so bad on my first fight with
Ashe where I wasn't thinking properly
and I was just trying to get as amped as
I could instead of being like like a sin
yeah oh what the [ __ ]
yeah your heart was probably racing like
a [ __ ] yeah that's why I think
like with fights um preferably I fight
someone I don't know and then I just
keep it level-headed cuz I think when
you fight with hate you don't fight the
right you don't
yeah you just like done it would be
pretty awesome if you would just get
that one in zero amateur record and then
people like oh you fought an amateur
fight how come you didn't fight anymore
it's just I was too good the level of
Zetas amateur I just didn't need it
anymore man yeah cuz right now you're
undefeated fighter I'm undefeated
I'm also undefeated for a year and a
half AB and if you don't count your
sparring I don't care just train
register
dude that video of rod so if you don't
know who Ron scolding is Ron is a pro
MMA fighter and he trains Bart there's a
video of Rodney checking your shin it
still hurts it sounded like somebody
dropped a bowling ball on on concrete
yeah it still hurts and it's been
probably three or four weeks now
that's [ __ ] crazy dude yeah there's a
lump here still it's it's light and it
went away but the medicine by accident
or it was just like that was what you
were training for well he that's just
how you check a kick so he was I throw
an inside leg kick and he just turned
this lake that's why I'm not coming back
same with these guys every morning I'm
like nah oh that's right you did trade
with them yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was
his wise idea he was like hey every now
and then you gotta do no shim pads so it
was a notion pads day that's
I'm like that's ty he's like if he can't
used to know shin pads then when he put
some pants on it's nothing I'm like all
right that's what Coach wants and then
he [ __ ] shin checks me my oh I've got
to work your way up I know I should
never again dude
well oh [ __ ] we're actually at the our
mark that was fast
almost yeah anyways guys the peacemakers
you [ __ ] baby AK okay well you know
what if you guys didn't know Bart
actually has his own podcast called the
barrel Castile cast deaw cast he
actually has it with his wife geo which
will bring her on here to talk her [ __ ]
as well so where can they check the bail
cast app you can type in Bart and geo on
YouTube or you could just type bail cast
on YouTube and it's also on iTunes so
you could check that out yeah everybody
check out her damn podcast man it's
gonna be on iTunes Spotify stitcher all
of our stuff is on every audio platform
out there
yep if you guys see it there give us
that five star and make sure that you
guys interact with all of our videos
write those comments say what's up
hopefully we'll put a clip of your
guys's fights on them you just [ __ ]
public this [ __ ] out of somebody's
[ __ ] face but yeah everybody will
catch you guys next time
and peace out to Toulouse peace